Once upon a time, Johnny Depp was the most
intriguing actor in Hollywood
Now, one hit franchise will usher in the end
of his creative choices, turning him into
a boring parody of himself...
But who cares? Now he owns a f**king island.
Pirates of the Caribbean.
Witness the Disneyfication of pirates, history’s
most notorious foul-mouthed rapists and murderers
where the cursing is PG,
"Pestilent, traitorous, cow-hearted, yeasty
codpiece."
"Ruthless, soulless, cross-grained cur."
'rape' becomes 'raid,'
"Raid, pillage, plunder and otherwise pilfer
my weasely black guts out."
and murder is physically impossible.
"You're not dead!"
"No!"
Buckle your swashes for Curse of the Black
Pearl, a straightforward adventure romp that
everyone loved
then Dead Man’s Chest, that everyone was
sort of on-board for, where they all betray
each other to find a
teleporting squid monster’s heart
At World’s End that everyone was totally
fed up with, where they all betray each other
while the squid monster teams up with the
British East India company
causing the pirate U.N. to release a sea goddess
who’s in love with the squid monster, except
for when she
isn’t,
and On Stranger Tides, that finally --
wait, what? They made a 4th one?
Ugh.
How many of these things can they do? They're
based on a f**king theme park ride for god's
sake!
Johnny Depp shines as Jack Sparrow
"Captain Jack Sparrow, if you please."
the legendary pirate made out of dreadlocks
and guyliner.
Watch this Oscar-worthy match between actor
and role as he hams it up with a trademark
barrage of
catchphrases,
"I'm Captain Jack Sparrow, savvy?"
"Savvy."
impractical escapes,
and silly walks
in this half-drunk Keith Richards impression
that really should be dead by now
kind of like Keith Richards.
"Does this face look like it's been to the
fountain of youth?"
Spend the rest of your time in the pale embrace
of the boring lovers Orlando Bloom and Keira
Knightley,
two perfect faces in the middle of a scurvy
ridden hellhole
whose will-they-won’t-they relationship
will have everyone
saying:
“Where did Jack Sparrow go?"
until they're replaced in the 4th one by their
cheaper, but just as pale, equivalents.
Baton down the hatches for nearly 10 overstuffed
maritime hours of
impossible sword fights,
stupid wigs,
terrible teeth,
alcoholism,
"Why is the rum gone?!"
"Why is the rum always gone?"
"Rum's gone too..."
"Hide the rum."
that song from the ride,
"Drink up, me hearties."
"Yo ho."
"Yo ho, a pirate's life for me."
"I love this song!"
and women dressed in cinema's least-convincing
boy disguises.
Mustache or not, I would totally pork that
dude.
Starring...
Captain Jack Spare Us From Any More of These
Movies,
Keira Daily,
Barnacle Bill,
Why Not Zoidberg?,
Finnicky,
Deadwoodmen Tell No Tales,
Captain Morgan,
Miss Cleo,
A Japanese Pornstar,
and Orlando Florida.
Jack Sparrow of the Caribbean (And Some Other
Pirates).
You used to be cool, man!
What the hell happened to you?
"Close your eyes and pretend it's all a bad
dream. That's how I get by."